Here is an example of a problem
related to the Bernoulli
process, which can be
tricky, but is actually
easy to answer if
one makes good use
of the fresh-start property.
Here is the setting.
Time is discrete,
divided into slots.
We have a server that
receives tasks to process.
Tasks received gets processed
in the same time slot.
So slots are divided
into busy ones--
those are the slots during
which a task gets processed.
And idle slots--
these are the slots
during which there is
no task to be processed.
We assume that the
process of job arrivals
is described by a
Bernoulli process
with some known parameter p.
So, during each slot
there is probability, p,
that a job is present,
and different slots
are independent of each other.
We're interested in the first
busy period of the server.
The first busy period
starts at the first slot
during which there
is a job present.
And the busy period
extends until just
before the next idle slot.
For an example, it
could be the case
that the first slot
is busy, in which case
the busy period
starts right here.
And the busy periods,
in this example,
extends for three time units.
It ends just before
the next idle slot.
It could also be the case
that the first slot is idle.
In that case, the
busy period starts
with the first busy
slot that shows up.
It's this slot in this example.
And extends until just
before the first idle slot
that we observe.
So in this example,
the busy period
extends for four time steps.
What is the length of
the first busy period?
Well, the length of
the first busy period
is a random variable.
So what we mean by
this question is,
what is the distribution
of this random variable?
Here's how we go about it.
The process starts, we wait
until a first busy slot
appears.
This is a random time, which
is actually the first arrival
time.
And at that time, by
our earlier discussion,
the process will start fresh.
Starting from this next the
slot here and going on forward,
what we have is a
Bernoulli process.
And at each slot, there's
probability p that it is busy,
and probability 1 minus
p that it is idle.
Now, what is this slot here?
This is the first idle slot
in this Bernoulli process
that starts fresh at
this particular time.
At each time step there
is probability 1 minus p
that the slot is idle.
Think now of idle
slots as successes.
How long does it take
until the first success?
We know that this is a geometric
random variable with parameter
equal to the
probability of success.
Since we're thinking of the
idle slot as being a success,
the parameter, in this case,
is going to be 1 minus p.
So, the length of
this blue interval
that starts at this
slot and extends
until the first idle slot
has a geometric distribution
with parameter 1 minus p.
But now notice that the
length of this blue interval
is exactly the same as the
length of this red interval.
The red interval is just the
same as the blue interval,
but shifted by 1, but
their lengths are the same.
And the length of
the red interval
is the length of the
first busy period.
So we conclude that the
first busy period is also
a geometric random variable
with parameter 1 minus p.